you know how um each like masseuse has a
different style like you were just
saying like some will go for the feed
some will like some like some do that
finger thing will like grab your finger
and go like this yeah
I I've been like trying to find a new
Barber there's like a new you know
hairdresser yeah
and they all do that too right they all
have different [ __ ] that they do some of
them end it you know they'll just clean
up your sideburns and then and then
that's that right and then some of them
have like a whole routine that they'll
do afterwards so I go to this new girl
and she she's one of the ones that like
doesn't let you watch so she turns you
away from the mirror you ever had that
oh yeah yeah so you can't watch yourself
get a haircut and that's probably for
people that are like stressed out like
during the cut or like can you whatever
I don't mind it it's a little stressful
like not being able to see yourself yeah
but uh she
like gets like basically finishes up and
I'm like okay cool she doesn't flip me
around and then she takes like a hot
towel out of the no she does she shaves
my neck with a straight rager razor and
like warm creams or whatever
but she had a straight rager dude cut my
neck up
during this straight rager
she she she shaves my neck and then I
hear like take out this like warm towel
from this like towel warmer that she has
she puts that on my thing tucks it into
my shirt I'm sitting there like oh this
feels nice yeah and then I hear her take
something else out and it's like
and all of a sudden I feel on my back
it's a back massager she's going in on
my shoulders and on my back and I'm like
oh it was really nice yeah
you're like hey
I'm engaged [ __ ] you can't do
all this
tweaking me out over here
but keep keep going yeah can we keep
going by the way
she's getting that tip yeah yeah she's
like you know she's pulling it out she's
like watch this you're all up right in
the [ __ ] oh
that's when your hands starts shaking
and you start leaving a crazy tip
[Laughter]
and a dog's leg is twitching this is
your hand
just writing 600 on the tip line
are you trying to do 60. yeah
matching zeros
how much are the beasts
[Laughter]
hella numbers it was awesome it was
awesome I'm definitely going back to her
I'm not sure yeah no I mean she
definitely earned your business with
that yeah you're like what are you doing
back oh
yeah he felt so guilty went home you're
like uh Kelsey uh this dude who cut my
hair today
no I was a guy like it was totally yeah
it was totally consensual like
just Strictly Business yeah in and out
you know easy
yeah this dude uh man he's got
yeah he's he's good he's good
light up a cigarette
damn
I mean everything reminds me of him
I just picture this this hairdresser
just observing all the people she cuts
just you know
it it's it's nothing to her it's just
part of the routine yeah and she's
watching all these people just
pulled over
here she's got like a like a Rolodex of
people like husbands you know wives yeah
just single people of all kinds just all
like filing in line like hey
I was thinking of you last week she's
like yeah back in the chair yeah yeah
and you're like oh God and she just
watches and melt yeah at the end every
time because I know when you finish up a
haircut you're like all right I'm ready
to get back to the business fresh yeah
fresh cut right I'm ready I'm ready
sitting up like this and then she pulls
up oh
oh she can't have people come in and see
her cutting other people's hair yeah
yeah getting jealous
I thought you only use that on me
you said I was your one and only one I
thought we had something special
no man in my Barbershop they use a
similar thing they use like the little
hand you know those ones right I think
that's what it was
like three balls on it no no this is
like a wolverine grip like you slide
your hand into it it's old school as
hell
and then they just put their hand on
your
like shoulders and it's like I don't
know how you describe it it's like a
massage myth they just literally like
slip it on and they just like kind of
Hit the shoulders in your upper back and
then you're done oh that's sick yeah
it's always funny because
there's such a you know it's such like a
test of masculinity yeah you know
there's no eye contact or they're always
trying to make conversation yeah
so what you got going on this weekend uh
we didn't do not much we just chilling
out
does that feel does that feel good no so
there's this kid no this is a young kid
keep going it doesn't feel good though
this is a young kid
he's he's getting he gets he finishes
the cut and my boy Tim it starts you
know going with the you know the girl
Wolverine yeah the Wolverine grip
and as it's as it starts going
I could see it in his eyes like he
starts to enjoy it but he goes hey nah
nah
cut that [ __ ] out
Tim was like oh no massage he's like nah
nah
and he gets [ __ ] at war with himself
bro his brain is at war with himself I
want to keep going so bad he wanted to
enjoy that [ __ ] so bad he shut down like
his shoulders got tight
no
no
yes no
no
keep going keep stopping stop
going stop going stop stop stop stopping
stop stopping
stop stopping bro
I said I said stop ping yeah
stop stopping
yeah so you want me to keep going yeah
keep going not doing it
yeah keep not doing it
go ahead keep it going
[Laughter]
but not doing it
so this is a normal thing then yeah that
normal thing so my old guy was [ __ ]
he was uh like not doing it so yeah what
the hell oh he is he's kind of scamming
me a little bit not even
improved I've never had it before he's
being that was the first time that I've
ever been massaged at the end of a thing
prude Barber yeah
damn yeah you must be Mormon or
something yeah what the [ __ ] yeah no I'm
pissed when this kid was like nah and he
like stood up I could tell
it was like
now he's gonna have to go back and tell
his friends yeah he was gonna have to
navigate that situation yeah you know
and then I'd know what was going to
happen was one of his friends who's
secure about themselves is gonna go oh
what you liked it you were afraid huh no
and then just melt his [ __ ] brain you
know he's gonna think about that moment
the rest of his life yeah
some girl's gonna be rubbing his back
he's gonna be like damn this is like the
time no it's not
no no
yeah yeah no it's a normal thing dude
you've been missing out damn yeah what
the [ __ ]